ein wunderschöner Morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen nicht mehr allzu
süßen Minecraft Welt meine lieben
Freunde an alle unter euch die die
letzte Episode Minecraft mit Luca nicht
gesehen haben da ist einiges passiert es
hat ein Überfall stattgefunden auf
unsere kleine Insel hier
stimmt
warum schwebt das scheiße in der letzten
Episode wurde meine Insel hier komplett
verwüstet und ihr seht schon an vielen
Stellen das Bäume beschädigt wurden
teilweise komplett abgetragen wurden
oder so wie ich hier einfach nur noch
verwüstet Aussehen es sieht ganz einfach
daran weil in der letzten Episode ein
Überfall stattgefunden hat auf meine
kleine Insel hier ich war ja vor zwei
Folgen in einer kleinen Kampfsituation
wo ich bei einem Außenposten von so
Pille Jon heißen sie glaube ich ein
bisschen Krawall gemacht habe und ich
dachte
das ist ja auch selbst schuld wenn die
sich dahin bauen auf jeden Fall waren
diese Räuber dann nicht so glücklich
darüber dass ich die ein bisschen
auseinander genommen habe und dann haben
die sich gedacht hey als Rache fällt
zugreifen wir einfach Lukas kleine Insel
an und das musste ich in Kauf nehmen ich
bin dabei auch gestorben von daher hoffe
ich jetzt mal dass wir quitt sind ihr
seht auch schon ich baue hier gerade
nebenbei alles mal so ein bisschen ab
weil ich bin ganz ehrlich ich möchte
jetzt nicht irgendwelche halbgaren Bäume
hier stehen lassen und mit Laub dann
irgendwie wieder auffrischen und dann
ist das so ein bisschen so wie wenn man
sich Kunstrasen in seinen Garten packt
das ist nicht halbe sondern auch nichts
ganzes Glas sieht dann wieder schön aus
und so wie vorher und man muss sich
nicht groß drum kümmern aber es geht mir
hier um die Natur und ich fühle mich
gerade so als würde ich hier über einen
Vortrag halten vor Fridays for future
oder so
es ist Minecraft luca ist einfach die
Kirche im Ball mein Ziel für die heutige
Episode Minecraft mit Luca ist es auf
jeden Fall dass unsere Insel wieder
schön wird es wird wenn jetzt so möchtet
eine Insel Reparatur 3.0 warum ist hier
vorne die Erde weg waren die das auch oh
Gott na ja ich bin mir aber leid dass
ich dann vielleicht immer so ein
bisschen überdramatisiert wirke und ein
bisschen zu emotional aber so
Kleinigkeiten neben den zerbrechlichen
Luca dann auch schon oftmals ein
bisschen mit das muss ich auch sagen und
vor allem wenn man über 30 Folgen lang
an dieser Insel gearbeitet hat dann Uhr
plötzlich Blöcke abgebaut werden Bäume
aus den Wurzeln gerissen werden dann
schlägt das bei mir gebrechlichen
Menschen ein bisschen aufs Herz von
daher tut's mir auch leid dass ich
vielleicht ein bisschen überreagiert
habe in der letzten Episode allerdings
soll es darum heute nicht mehr gehen
sondern wir bauen hier alles neu auf ihr
seht schon ich habe gerade den Baum hier
mit der Schaukel abgebaut was hältst Du
davon das ist ja der Witz Baum einziger
Witz hier bist du den hatten wir bereits
ist immer noch nicht lustig allerdings
wenn ich auf das hier unten mal abbauen
das war nämlich vorher glaube ich noch
oder war das schon
Pilz der hier bleibt auf jeden Fall
stehen der hat ja schon Kult
mittlerweile in diesem Projekt hier der
Dings
der Luke Crew Baum fehlt seit Folgen der
wird aber mal direkt alles hier stehen
und liegen gelassen guck mal hier vorne
Alter die ist ja auch alles hier kaputt
gemacht worden der lucreenbaum den habe
ich ja seit Folgen nicht mehr wieder
aufgebaut was bin ich denn für ein Idiot
guck mal den hier vorne bei euch aber
auch noch mal eben ab die Sache ist oder
musste hier auch immer so ein bisschen
geht davon eigentlich auch der Bogen
kaputt wenn ich hier zur Sachen abbaue
ich weiß es nicht ich nehme einfach mal
die Ofenkartoffeln davon könnte ich mir
kurz noch eine reinhauen
[Musik]
hat jetzt gerade gesagt
was ist denn hier los allerdings stehen
nicht nur die Tiere auf meiner Seite
sondern auch ihr was diese ganze
überfallsituation hier anging denn die
Kommentare waren wirklich voll mit
positiven Feedback von euch geh mal rein
hier oder trinkst hier also nee du erst
ja was machen denn Tiere die eigentlich
im Wasser leben dann an Land
ja gut dann chill mal weiter da vorne
wir konzentrieren uns jetzt auf jeden
Fall hier wieder auf den Wiederaufbau
und da an der Stelle wie bereits vorhin
schon angedeutet ganz kurz noch mal ein
riesiges Dankeschön an euch für euren
extrem Geisteskranken Support wir waren
in den deutschen Youtube Trends glaube
ich wieder auf Platz 4 oder so das kann
ich immer noch nicht händeln dass jede
Folge so krass bei euch ankommt warte
mal die Eichen Setzlinge brauche ich
doch noch denn ich werde mir so ein paar
verschiedene Bäume hier auf meine Insel
hauen unter anderem auch die Birken den
Toten Busch kann ich auch endlich mal
mitnehmen und auch meinen Ton ich weiß
nicht wo ich den hingepackt hatte hier
vorne war der hier vorne einfach mal in
den Ofen hauen so dass wir uns auch die
Blumentöpfe für heute machen können und
ich will allerdings erstmal sagen
ich lasse mich schon wieder viel zu
krass ablenken danke auf jeden Fall für
euer riesiges Feedback ich suche mir
jetzt die Setzlinge raus und kurz eine
timelaps für euch jetzt hier dann an der
Stelle
Weltfrieden
so meine lieben Freunde ich habe da mal
so ein bisschen Items sortiert da war ja
in der letzten Folge noch nicht so
richtig die Zeit für weil ich ja dann
doch sehr emotional war über die ganze
Situation hier mit meiner Insel ihr seht
schon unten ich habe einen weißen
Farbstoff in der Hand und möchte mal
ganz kurz hey Schwein
hey wie süß ist das das plötzlich jeder
voll auf meiner Seite ist seitdem jetzt
die Situation mit dem Überfall hatten
naja ich werde erstmal auch ganz kurz
hier noch mal das Knochenmehl nehmen und
hier alles ein bisschen schöner machen
plus ich möchte heute jetzt auch dass er
noch ein bisschen Insel Reparatur auch
richtig schreibt jetzt nicht in Titel
weil dann ist bin ich mal so sehe nicht
dann fühle ich mich immer so gezwungen
mich so komplett krass darum zu kümmern
weil nach der ersten reparaturfolge ja
viele mein äh also fast gar nichts
repariert von daher ganz äh clean
gewählter Titel von mir wir reparieren
unsere Insel oder wir holen die ich ja
keine Ahnung wie ich das Video nennen
werde ich möchte auf jeden Fall mal ganz
kurz äh das Schweinchen hier wieder weiß
färben tada
geht jetzt nicht ich brauche nämlich
weiße Wolle der fragt mich jetzt
wahrscheinlich Luca wofür brauchst du
denn die weiße Wolle ich möchte mir
Teppiche machen und
muss die Werkbank keine Ahnung habe ich
die Werkbank ja damals da stehen
gelassen habe wo ich auf das
ozeanmonument gewartet habe bzw das
Ozean Moment rein wollte ich brauche auf
jeden Fall erstmal hier von bisschen
Teppich und hiervon brauche ich auch
noch drei Teppiche denn ich habe mir
auch schon das hier mitgenommen
Eichenholz Zäune und ihr seht auch
bereits Akazien Setzlinge und
Knochenmehl der ein oder andere
erfahrene Minecraft Spieler
weiß dass ich erst schlafen gehen sollte
weil ich sonst wieder von Creepern in
die Luft gejagt werde der ein oder
andere erfahrene Minecraft Spieler weiß
direkt schon was ich vorhabe und zwar
möchte ich hier vorne kann ich das ja
eigentlich mal machen einen Baum
hinsetzen jetzt habe ich natürlich
wieder keine Erde damit ich Idiot
zieh mir mal ganz kurz hier sonnenblock
setzt ihn hier hin
ja ist doch schön und mit ganz viel
Glück das hoffe ich was ist das das ist
ein Fisch
ist
da ist mein Boot mit ganz viel Glück und
das möchte ich so ein bisschen erzwingen
geht der Akazienbaum hier so rüber es
wird extrem geil von daher gucken wir
mal ob wir das hinkriegt und er macht
das ist das
[Musik]
ist fast zu lang wie mein Penis
wollen wir ein Baum anzünden ein paar
Sekunden später
ich liebe dieses Projekt na ja wir
konzentrieren uns nicht mehr auf diesem
brennenden Baum da vorne warum brennt
jetzt hier der Boden
das geht jetzt aber nicht rüber oder
du bist eine Schildkröte du kannst nicht
brennen das kann ich doch zeigen guck
mal hier Feuerzeug auf die Schildkröte
tschuldigung warum brennt denn mein
Strand hier jetzt ab was soll denn das
hier der Ding soll
brennt nicht naja das kriegt ja ja schon
selber hin ich würde sagen wir
konzentrieren uns erstmal so ein
bisschen auf den Boden damit hier wieder
alles so ein bisschen verwucherter
aussieht mir auch immer viele
geschrieben Luca sieht doch gar nicht so
schön aus wenn da so viel Gras ist doch
krass ist gut also bitte nicht aus dem
Kontext ziehen jetzt die Aussage auch
guck mal
da müssen wir auch die Tage dran
weiterbauen freue ich mich auch schon
drauf da hinten alles so einen leichten
Nebel gehüllt hier soll ja die Tierinsel
hin hier vorne das soll er die
Blumeninsel werden die will mal
runterziehen aber das ist nicht das
Thema für heute denn wir möchten heute
alles ein bisschen schöner machen ne
perfekt danke mache ich ah ist schon
fast fertig das heißt wir können
eigentlich wieder nach da hinten laufen
ich habe zu Beginn des heutigen Videos
auch hinten schon die Fackeln entfernt
da äh wollte ich eigentlich sagen warum
ich das gemacht habe denn ich möchte
auch in der heutigen Folge wenn es schon
so ein bisschen Insel Reparatur ist
alles so ein bisschen durch Steinmauern
ersetzen sodass warum wächst du nicht
wachsmal was sagt ein kleiner Stift ein
großer zum wachsmal ich weiß nicht ob
wir damit zufrieden sind aber ich lasse
einfach mal stehen und werde mich jetzt
auf das konzentrieren was ich erstmal
gerade sagen wollte Luca bleibt beim
Thema
ich habe es vergessen ich sitze hier
erstmal ein Birkenbaum hin und äh hau da
ein bisschen Knochenmehl drauf denn ich
benötige ein bisschen Birkenholz für
eine kleine Strand liegen und Strand
Sonnenschirm Situation die hier vorne
stattfinden soll deswegen wollte ich
eigentlich dass der so ein bisschen
übers Wasser drüber geht da der das
jetzt nicht gemacht hat ist das
vielleicht aber auch ganz gut weil man
sich dann hier vorne hinlegen kann so
ein bisschen ich weiß dass so Strand
liegen und vor allem so ein Strand
Schirm Sonnenschirm
dingsbumsbums Bims
ganz schweres Ding gewesen ich weiß dass
das eigentlich tendenziell eher mehr
Sinn macht bei unserer komischen Strand
in die komisch ist sie nicht die sehr
modern und sehr schön ich glaube dass
sich viele denken dass es eigentlich
dort mehr Sinn macht die Sache ist
allerdings dass ich da dass ich das hier
machen will ich weiß nämlich dass unsere
Villa da hinten noch ein bisschen dauern
wird von daher möchte ich jetzt erstmal
ganz kurz mir hier vorne so eine kleine
liege hinstellen und als ein bisschen
schön machen so dass wir nicht nur alles
neu aufbauen in der heutigen Folge
sondern noch etwas hinzufügen also hier
so eine kleine liege und dann
beispielsweise hier noch so eine mehr
über Eck machen so ein bisschen so
vielleicht dass man hier dann so sitzen
kann und dann nehme ich mir jetzt meine
Zäune und die Teppiche denn ich möchte
so ein Rot-Weißen Schirm machen an ähm
Mayonnaise und Ketchup angelehnt so
heftig mal kurz hier drauf und kann
jetzt hier einfach den Teppich
drauflegen und hier an die Seite
und hier an die Seite
geht das nicht
soll ich mit das
gesehen
weißt du das Flipper
die haben viel mehr noch einmal wieder
getroffen seit was ist das denn
[Musik]
ja das nicht letzte schon mal geboxt was
ist das der hat sich aufgepumpt das Mann
[Musik]
was der hier ist das eine
ja okay okay wow ich lasse ihn in Ruhe
ich lass sie in Ruhe wir konzentrieren
uns nicht auf Flipper oder irgendwas was
im Wasser ist habe ich eh Schiss vor das
sieht schon schön aus das sieht schon
schön aus also ein bisschen übers der
Wasser wäre vielleicht ein bisschen noch
schöner gewesen aber wir konzentrieren
uns erstmal hier drauf denn ich glaube
wirklich das Teppich nicht in der Luft
schweben kann wenn irgendwer von euch da
wieder so pro Player Tipps habt dann
schreibt mir das gerne unten in die
Kommentare allerdings gehe ich jetzt
erstmal den Weg dass ich das ganze hier
so baue dann setze ich nämlich hier
einen hin dann setze ich noch hier vorne
ein hin und setze ich noch hier einen
hin so und noch hier vorne frag ich
jetzt wahrscheinlich Luca warum das
sieht überhaupt nicht gut aus ja wartet
ab so oder mache ich hier so dann kann
ich nämlich hier dran wieder
warum hat man mich abonniert hier vorne
kommt dann noch eine birkenholzfalte
dran und hier auch und dann hier vorne
wieder zack dann gehen wir hier rüber
und warum ich die Teile gebaut habe weiß
ich jetzt auch nicht
also irgendwie ist auch nicht alles
Silber was Gold gelandet
sehr ganz komische Folge heute es tut
mir leid ich weiß nicht wo meine letzte
Birkenholz Falltür ist allerdings muss
ich mir dann wohl zwangsläufig noch mal
neue machen hier vorne rüber zack die
eben eingesammelt und hier das sieht
schon schön aus also klar da fehlt was
aber so von oben vielleicht sieht man
dann den roten Teppich dann auch guck
mal
das hier weg ist und so
das sieht schon schön aus dann wollen
wir hier noch so eine kleine Situation
zack wir können hier noch kommen das
mache ich auch noch eben Alter wow
wir kümmern uns überhaupt nicht um die
Insel Reparatur sondern nur meine neue
Strandliege ich benötige für das was ich
vorhabe noch mal vier Stück von denen
dann äh kann ja nur direkt hier meinen
Ton mitnehmen bzw packe dann noch mal
eben kurz ein bisschen mehr Kohle rein
ich habe einfach so viel Kohleblöcke das
unfassbar hier einer sollte ja reichen
zack du wieder zurück hier rein das geht
jetzt voll
das ist auch essen Stress hier wir
müssen auf jeden Fall demnächst
irgendwann
die ganze kistensortierung ein bisschen
genauer unter die Lupe nehmen denn ich
mache mir sogar noch einen mehr glaube
ich mache mir insgesamt mal fünf denn
meine lieben Freunde ich möchte nicht
mehr hier oben die ganzen Kisten Sachen
drin haben sondern da oben wirklich
entscheidend mit sondern verzauber nicht
verzaubern sondern wie heißt das denn
verdrängten drinking dies mit diesen
Tränken möchte ich da auf jeden Fall
machen und hier vorne auch guck mal wie
sexy das da oben glitzert
[Musik]
ich möchte diesen Raum hier komplett zu
einem kistenraum machen und ich glaube
das macht auch Sinn denn dann haben wir
da oben alles so ein bisschen was braun
angeht da möchte ich mich nämlich in den
nächsten Folgen generell ein bisschen
mit auseinandersetzen weil wir auch ins
Ozean Moment wollen dann haben wir die
ganzen Kisten drin und wenn wir
verzaubern wollen können wir das ja da
hinten auf der Zauberinsel machen und
dieses Portal hier wird auch in der
nächsten Folge umgebaut wir haben Nacht
was ist denn das so schnell passiert
Alter what ist das echt Zombies kommen
auf jeden Fall möchte ich hier unten
auch noch etwas rausmachen
frag mich jetzt wahrscheinlich was
[Musik]
wenn wir irgendwie angegriffen werden
können wir dann immer runter in unseren
Schutzbunker geben von daher ist das
auch noch steht das auch noch auf dem
auf dem Stand von den Dingen warum bin
ich denn jetzt hier
soll ich denn hier machen
ich wollte gar nichts machen ich wollte
schlafen gehen da ich in den 10 Minuten
danach in dieser Episode völlig verpeilt
war mache ich euch einfach ganz kurze
timelapse wie ich ein paar Bäume aufbaue
wie ich meine liegen Situationen auch
ein bisschen schöner baue und wie ich
Erde abbaue allerdings machen wir jetzt
an dieser Stelle hier weiter
[Musik]
warum
warum sind hier schon wieder diese
Idioten sag bitte nicht
das ist ich lasse ihn in Ruhe
ich habe wir sind quitt die kommen rüber
die kommen rüber zu mir warum in Gottes
Namen sind die noch hier ich habe die
besiegt die haben mich getötet und
danach habe ich die besiegt wir sind
sowas von quit und jetzt sind die hier
und Schwimmen zurück zu meiner Insel
warum das kann doch nicht sein der
Überfall ist doch vorbei wie kann das
denn sein Freunde schreibt mir bitte in
die Kommentare was ich falsch gemacht
habe und warum die jetzt wieder hier bei
mir sind aber ich habe keinen Bock mich
mit denen zu beschäftigen weil ich
einfach nur meine Insel reparieren will
ich verstehe es nicht es kann doch nicht
möglich sein dass die hier wieder
angeschwommen kommen wo sind sie
listet euch gerne auf der Insel ein
machtau euer Ding ich habe einfach nur
entspannt hier meine Erde geholt weil
ich meine Insel heute reparieren möchte
und ich will keinen Stress allerdings
ist jetzt erstmal alles aufgestockt also
ihr seht hier unten da ist kein
sandblock mehr da irgendwie stört in der
Optik hier vorne das muss halt erstmal
zu Gras werden dann kann ich da den äh
Dings noch mal weitermachen den Weg
allerdings würde ich sagen dass wir
erstmal ganz kurz pennen gehen guck mal
die komisch das hier alles aussieht
Alter die ganzen Bäume nicht mehr stehen
ich fühle mich total irgendwie auf der
ganzen Insel naja ach guck mal das schon
wieder neue Wolle bekommen das ist sehr
nice kann ich mir noch mal ganz kurz
mitnehmen Zack und hier vorne ja das
müssen wir alles demnächst noch mal
abarbeiten ich sehe schon kommen dass
das schwarze Brett voller wird als
unsere ganze Insel zusammen allerdings
möchte ich mich jetzt wirklich auf das
konzentrieren final hier zum Ende der
Folge was wir angehen wollten guck mal
wie leer [ __ ] das aus ich weiß viele
wollten das dass die Insel ein bisschen
weniger Bäume hatte allerdings finde ich
das sehr schön wenn wir so ein bisschen
Natur hier haben den Baum hier vorne den
lasse ich einfach mal so das ist ein
bisschen funny eigentlich sogar weil es
ja der witzbaum ist dann kommt das
eigentlich relativ gut hin hier an der
Seite fehlt ein Blatt das heißt
sämtliche an der Seite sogar dann auch
noch mal immer abnehmen und hier vorne
auch so das Schaf
hat auf jeden Fall auch abgenommen wir
konzentrieren uns jetzt mal darauf dass
wir hier die Bäume ein bisschen
hochkriegen ich werde hier vorne jetzt
einfach mal so eine Fichte hinsetzen ich
weiß nicht wie das aussehen wird und ob
eine Fichte wirklich auf unsere Insel
passt allerdings
wer ihr zwei Idioten klaut mir da hinten
quarzblöcke
ich würde eigentlich sagen jetzt ist
Krieg aber ich ich habe hier keine
Motivation wieder für irgendeinen Streit
ich will mich jetzt erstmal ein bisschen
aufbauen konzentrieren der sieht auf
jeden Fall sehr schön aus hier vorne
sehe ich eine Birke eigentlich die
können wir hier hinsetzen zack guck mal
auch sehr schön dann nehme ich noch mal
ganz kurz die Eiche da können wir hier
vorne eine Eichel hinsetzen so hier so
ein bisschen zack sieht auch schön aus
guck mal das Schaf hat schon wieder
Alter der vermehrt sich ja wie äh Fisch
auf dem äh Dings offen den großen Baum
habe ich stehen lassen jetzt habe ich
hier zwischen auch so ein bisschen Blick
hinten auf die Tierinsel dann demnächst
das ist auch sehr schön noch eine Spinne
guck mal einer an
hier vorne
und Leute fahren jetzt hier
[Musik]
ich habe draußen gehört dass ich dachte
jemand bohrt über mir und das ist ja
doof für die Aufnahme aber draußen sehen
ich glaube daher geflogen und in dem
Moment kommt ein creep aus
[Musik]
aufbauen ja auch noch mal ganz kurzer
timelapse wie ich den Wasserfall wieder
repariert habe einige neue Bäume
gepflanzt habe und generell die Inseln
ein bisschen repariert habe doch jetzt
geht's weiter mit einer sehr traurigen
Situation was ich auf jeden Fall noch
machen wollte weil hier ganz kurz eben
die Blätter wegpacken zack zack und hier
das letzte und ich wollte auch noch mal
eben Balu hier bzw die ganzen
Schildkröten chillen ja auch hier drin
rum ich wollte ich schlag nur die
Schildkröte mein Boot hä
wie kriege ich denn mein Boot hier raus
[Musik]
Katze
und
Schildkröte ich wollte die nicht töten
ich wollte nur meinen Boot zurück haben
[Musik]